in the council building all 27 member
states meet and discuss European policy
issues and try to find a common position
we have different kinds of meetings we
have experts we have ambassadors they
meet at the level of Ministers and
finally of course heads of state and
government as the so called European
Council for all these meetings to be
successful you need basically two
ingredients policy advice to the
presidency and logistical support to the
meetings I think probably the best way
to understand how we work is to see
European Council in action from the
backstage
sarcasm edifice in Yokohama ever seen
surpass panel the tyranny Deacon filled
only capital family in your organization
telecommute travelrama element on
America secretary-general you can say
I'm very focused and I'm focused because
much is at stake
the future of our currency or economy
and we have to take it all this very
seriously
Bahasa mayor news mo boos were the same
jeweler the paper has shown they pulled
the materials I've always wondered was
Ruth
we're into the Italian language now 25
pages each each language version my main
responsibility is to prepare in this
case the treaty which will be signed on
the 2nd of March today we are preparing
the text it should fit perfectly this is
a signature ceremony you want it to be
as easy as possible and to run as
smoothly as possible so that's the
simple reason why we're doing this
so yesterday both you pay em hey refer
to the possibility that the arms would
table the new resolution in New York I
would say that we integrated in his
speaking points for the introduction
External Relations Syria Arab Spring
there's of course one subject which in
it which is still under discussion so we
have to wait for the discussions of of
today because there may be still a
couple of problems around
we have high-ranking visitors with the
President of the European Council is the
president of service things are not over
Serbia didn't reach candidate status we
try to fix the problem
probably this evening if it is not
possible we have to discuss it at the
European Council Thursday I had to show
that the sequence heaters of the Dos
Equis drafted deal away on under a
minute
classic there is a positive confirmation
of the criteria being met but the
decision is not being taken I have a
meeting with the director general of the
WTO Pascal language do you know this
decision that's not real he sees an open
source economy visit method of
architecture
camera priests blow more so if it's
clogged answer is recessed emails on
what publicity camera or image club so
second is to determine the seniority
apparently chef please answer - boo
top line in those
it when the speech value from the
auditor will be take another example I
like to crack and press conferences for
brides and the attribute the water
defend the pass by the mom and Akbar he
to pass it back in now the elopement
many of our passion so and then I try to
reorganize around the three key keywords
crisis trust and unconference a lot will
be on the agenda as well as further
accession to the Schengen area
no not one of those movie people she'll
help us
Alison Sicily the montage at their table
will shape the time the grotto safety in
grant tab cafe all symmetric elk they
don't collaborate the Sun nap if people
are deeply in for tourism it's any sort
of video streaming plan planned for the
signing ceremony of the fiscal compact
summons are the big thing for all the
journalists here and it's and therefore
is also the big thing for us the
spokespeople
we will try to make available quickly
was what agreed on Syria here to do the
circus the day a minute may oversee the
dossier polar Kayla and demeanors
personnel the president's a collaborator
head and SSA who didn't attend healing
it was
to tabiet referee made food to rule and
occur that's it no problem Nach Baliye
we have to show the ship please a
provision and we're here today on the
eve of a European Council practically
I'm responsible for making sure that
tomorrow when the heads of state and
government come for European Council
they have all they need to do their work
properly it's quite a big job it's like
running a small village making sure that
everything is there so that the leaders
can take the right decisions
don't want ye to super extra pious a
year and test your only problem it
applies to a complex for an interior
addition did you deny this meeting this
morning is with President Barroso and
President Van Rompuy we are planning the
day basically let's go to the agenda of
the European Council the name of Central
European Council is much much different
in terms of concept of any summit that
could be held anywhere in the world the
difference between all of those and us
is that we do it on a whole most monthly
basis
fiscal consolidation remains unavoidable
to keep our social bubble sustained it
is a very busy day will end after
midnight the president we have good news
now concerning the new candidate status
that they have brought agreement and
signed this meeting protocol and we hope
that this will no paper way to decision
without discussion
let's get to the personas all right
handed
we have a number of participants in this
room as you can see we have a local
police for the outside perimeter we have
the Federal Police for export purposes
and we do have the Belgian special
forces in the house also for a
protective mission for a country on a
higher threat level but also for
interior protection we have people on
roofs and here people are standby close
to the main meeting room all these
people together coordinate in case of
major events
very big day for you
we've got any interesting no really
welcome you all you do your P's got what
the most important thing about
interpreting is not the words it's not
the language itself it's the the message
it's the spirit of what's being put
across
we have instantly to understand what
people are trying to say and to convey
that message in the same tone in the
same spirit
it's excellent day it's a second mandate
let's get started
or now evil honor his nose conjugal in
30 seconds you are there
I'm very honored that you have all
decided to ask me to continue as
president of the European Council for a
second mandate today we have 1800
equality journalists in the press
there is a lot of information flowing in
this area from delegations from
institutions etc more or less informally
and therefore we have to try to always
keep things into context try to give
them
indications on what's being discussed on
timing - confidence in LA and total nan
Batian up know what enough to not have
to amend fact the most high collar Punta
Omaha more button-down at last news -
penis react for the for the press
conference
during this council we have a wide range
of issues to discuss continuing this
work for Europe in some designs times is
a privilege and responsibility
keep in touch 50 spotted horse possessed
any manner of crap mr. Seagal a mahogany
suka he hear her comment here often
Houghton typical Indian family I have
she couldn't wish to do as the CJ entus
here in this job
this Gator hunters my life after 32
Padano flees the suspension Biscayne and
dr. feelgood is a little DVD chef that I
don't initiate d'etat he does another no
particular but was the bachelor unit
sample SOPs our cameras are
more than the normal teenage report put
it all the time only pretty facility
don't care initial data handle I sell
all of them all a PI server bodies
imagine a people perspective Saku hard
water goes suppose having some lap or
appellee block a loja the other fella to
show everyone signed as you can see
about four five minutes to go around the
round the room so short and sweet
it's a done deal
what you see here is dedicated teams of
translators and assistants servicing
exclusively the summit meeting everyone
wants to get as fast as possible
diversions in their own languages which
allows them to give a final check to the
conclusions
we should start in about five minutes
I'm just gonna place you on hold until
we start hello everybody
Tonkin photography manasik European
debriefing publishes delegation in
ordinary parts curve AV demolishes no
delegation the Castillo of explications
Paso Nevada conservative exit rate a new
initiative a basically basically our
responsibility a solidarity yes a
decision official likened a tool a
selfie when your appearance at the back
layer new to ya quelqu'un zoo
one assuredly tool a problem photocopies
the deer should switch around a satisfy
a press and only waitress on top